so again my name is beyond I'm one of
the cofounders of company called source
graph for those of you don't know source
graph is a semantic code search engine
that lets you explore browse and search
all the open source code available on
the web and also the code inside your
company we index most of the go open
source world so if you use a lot of go
open source and you know one a great
tool for exploring code and reading it
and finding use of samples and learning
how best to use you know given function
or method check us out we're actually
coming out of private beta soon that
will let you download source graph and
run it on your private code so if you
know you have trouble with like
searching for code or exploring on your
private code or are unhappy with your
code review process contact me or one of
the other source graph people at words
we can send you the link the private
beta so this still does not work
must be moon
that's what that's like assumed ok so
the slides for this talk are at this
link github com so I've source graph /
box I'm going to be doing a recap of
gopher con so you know we were doing the
official live blog at going on so we
wrote up you know detailed technical
summaries of all the talks that we saw
there and so this talk is mostly going
to be pointing you to the links to those
descriptions so you can see for yourself
that's the best way to do recap i'm at
the one who came up with all these great
talks and ideas it's best you got it
straight food source and that'll be up
for you know the next couple of weeks
i'm told that the video should be up
within two weeks so look for that and
that comes out but yeah with that let's
just dive right in so you know go around
2015 this year was an awesome conference
is the second annual gopher con there
are fifteen hundred attendees which is
more than double what it was the year
before which is amazing and there are a
lot of great companies well represented
there that are using go so there's kind
of the usual suspects you know docker
core OS twitch mesosphere data dog
clucks DB and source graph but they're
also you know some companies that you
might not have expected we're using go
in production at scale these included
comes like verizon comcast Aetna which
is one of the largest EHR providers in
the nation healthcare gov uses go that
you go in there be right that actually
got the site to work
and Cisco uses go and so again there's
the link to the live blog but some
high-level themes that we noticed
covering the conference this year two
big themes three big themes that pop out
at us where the themes of like building
the community the history of the
language and using go in enterprise so
delving into each of those community was
a big theme in some of the key talks at
the conference this year the focus is
around recognizing that you know what
makes a language for me strong is not
just the language itself or the
technology around it but also the people
that comprise the community and I think
that's one of that's been one of the key
assets of the NGO community so far it's
a community of passionate people who are
dedicated to building things in practice
that has made really made you know go
the strong language that is today that
has been used in a bunch of companies in
production and moving forward you know
we need to be conscious of the fact that
you know the strength of the of the NGO
community is really based on you know
how many people we can really convince
to adopt go and use it inside of
companies and as part of that effort we
need to be mindful of you know making
the community feel welcome continuing to
make the community feel welcoming to
newcomers to the community especially
those from you know groups that have
been traditionally underrepresented in
the broader tech community and in doing
so will create a more diverse culture
that will strengthen you know the
diversity of ideas that are present the
language and we'll basically made go
that much better of a community
language to be a part of studies have
shown that you know monocultures are not
as robust to change and evolution as
organizations and groups with a lot of
diversity and so this was a point that
you know a lot of the the go poor people
at Google really emphasize go has done
very well as me thus far in kind of
building a culture of inclusiveness and
moving forward we only need to do a
better job of that to make sure that we
can really spread go to every corner of
the earth so Andrew grand Andres Cox
talked about no drafting up a code of
conduct that would kind of put down
writing the sort of guidelines to direct
the community moving forward and another
point that was brought up was the fact
that the NGO community has been a big
contributor to you know go thus far you
know we've implemented a lot of
additions to go we ported it to new
platforms we've added new features
contributor the standard library but
thus far a lot of the design the high
level design docs and proposals have
mostly been offered by people within
Google and that's kind of weird because
you know look at all the names of the
companies are using go today you know
Google is just one name among many and
goes in a really an open source
community project and so another you
know document that is now up is this
change proposal process by which if
people in the community can propose a
change that they want to make
to language get a reviewed by the core
contributors the language and so go
through a general process instead of
having to kind of operate by the sort of
unspoken rules by which that is taking
place up to this point and another talk
that was really inspiring kind of in the
theme of you know community and being
welcoming to newcomers and language was
Audrey limbs talk so this was a woman
who like a year ago literally was a
lawyer who had zero programming
experience and within a year you know
she learned to go as her first serious
in a back-end programming language and a
year later she has a development job at
nitrous I oh and so it kind of
counteracts the the notion in in some
circles that go is kind of like a
serious you know complex systems
language that is inaccessible to
beginners here's a person who learned go
as basically her first language and was
able to spin up not only on the language
but also a bunch of course yes concepts
in the process that was worth cool so
another big topic was history in general
like historical context both in terms of
how go has evolved over time and you
know what are the roots ago where did it
come from so you know the five probably
perhaps the most five most influential
languages in the goal in edge or Algol
60 Pascal see ma Jella and Oberon and
these were covered in Robert Reese Mars
talk on the evolution of go and i highly
encourage everyone to go take a look at
that it was super informative he
basically went on like a whirlwind tour
of programming language
history over the past like 30 or 40
years and it's really fascinating to see
like a lot of the features and concepts
that we you know really like and go and
they make go elegant see where they came
from so go began with this question you
know that was asked among rest uh
not not risk oxygen Thompson Rob pipe
and Robert recent where you know what
should a modern programming language
look like and I think who was but
someone made the joke that they asked
this question while waiting for some C++
code to compile reason like that so they
began with this question and early on
you know there was a lot of informal
discussion between the three of them is
a very informal consensus driven process
and it's interesting to note that early
on you know most of the features
proposed by through them were rejected
by the other two in the party they came
from very different worlds and so they
had kind of like a very diverse set of
opinions and thoughts around you know
what a modern programming language
should look like over time that kind of
original vision was solidified into an
actual language and you know sort of
philosophy began to a CO less around the
language and I think Russ Cox summed
this up very well in his opening keynote
in this phrase do less enable more so go
is all about you know doing less not
implementing all the language features
out there that will enable the language
to reach you know 99 percent the use
cases but you know focusing on a smaller
core set of primitives that maybe cover
eighty percent of the use cases that
people want and then enabling people to
build more complex solutions on top of
that strong core so this was a recurring
theme in his talk do less enable more
and then you know again Robert P summer
touch upon this
you know a lot of critics of go say that
the language doesn't really innovate in
any real way they're not we're not
advancing the state of the art and you
know programming language design and
Robert had this great point in his talk
about you know you know taking from see
CA are 20 core yeah this thought that
the task of a program language designer
is not so much you know innovation but
more consolidation like looking at the
past seeing what has worked well in
practice and incorporating those ideas
in an elegant way and you know moving
looking forward Andrew grin so I entered
your and talked a lot about how how the
NGO community and the processes have
evolved from the early days of you know
consensus-driven informal discussions to
now you know like a worldwide community
that is very adopting a little bit more
process to facilitate you know more
diversity and contributions from the
community it's still the early days for
a go you know even though we've come a
long way from when it was just like an
internal project inside Google we are
still kind of at the cusp of adoption in
the broader mainstream enterprise and
that kind of segues well into the third
large theme that we noticed which was
this idea that you know go is now
becoming a mainstream language in the
enterprise and it's probably only going
to become more so in the next couple of
years and so Peter Bergen and his talk
he talked about go kit which is his it's
basically like a proposal for a set of
libraries for writing you know
distributed web services inside large
companies and a big motivation behind
doing this is that up until now a lot of
people have said you know it goes a
great language
for at the system's level to replace you
know core infrastructure but a lot of
people still say you know I prefer you
know Ruby or Python or Java for the
application layer logic that encodes the
quote unquote business logic go kid one
of its goals is to really change that
discussion and convince people that go
is is really a general-purpose language
that's easy to use and is great for her
developing things of the application
layer as well and then there is just a
whole slew of talks that were of you
know the form you know we wrote or
rewrote our system and go and it's
worked amazingly well so those are great
case studies to look at if you know
you're looking to grow the use of you go
inside your company so beyond uh you
know just the the talks that fit into
those three general themes there you
know a whole other there are a lot of
talks that were just you know very
interesting and useful so a lot of
useful tools new features best practices
were discussed so to meet you if I have
talked about some great dynamic tools
that he's developed like the like go
fuzz which can help you test your go
programs robustly derek parker talked
about this really awesome new debugger
he's created that helps you debug go
programs ben johnson hunter like we'll
talk about using the the go SS a package
in the standard library to do static
analysis i think one of the biggest
advantages of go is the fact that kind
of the internals of the compiler and a
str so readily accessible to to users of
the language we have the standard
library Hanna Kim talked about go from
mobile devices so now you can write go
and have it cross compile down to iOS
and
android which is awesome Rick Hudson had
a really interesting talk about
designing the garbagemen redesigning the
garbage collector in version 1.5 to make
it I think more than two orders of
magnitude faster in terms of or I
shouldn't say faster two orders of
magnitude smaller in GC pauses with very
little trade-off in overall performance
of course there was Brad Fitzpatrick's
talk about generics and go one point six
yeah just kidding that was an actual
talk Catherine Cox per day talked about
simplicity and go and is great talk kind
of questioning this notion of simplicity
simplicity simplicity is like a common
refrain you hear in the go language
community but too often is kind of used
as like a crux for like I'm just going
to say simplicity and like end of
discussion so he was talking about yeah
what does that actually mean I which
actually think about you know whether
simplicity helps achieve our goals or
not Tomas and Hart talked about you know
using interfaces to design various
patterns and go he talked about how how
he came upon this were like really cool
pattern that was basically the
equivalent of the decorator pattern in
other languages using interfaces and Sam
Hellman howarth talked about how do you
struck tags language feature that's
probably useful but beginners might not
know exactly how to use use it there's
no real like official documentation
about you know what is the structure of
a struct tagging one that should be like
Sarah Adams talked about you're
generating code for the sake of
consistency in your code base and Kevin
Cantwell talked about in a bunch of
gotchas that might like you
we need to go and in addition to just
the main talks there were a whole bunch
of lighting talks it's like entire day
of lightning talks many thanks to Bill
Kennedy for covering those you should go
check them out I think there are a lot
of good talks in there one of the talks
was from the the person who kind of led
the effort to be implemented care gov
from like a messy enterprise Java app in
two like a smooth sleek 21st century go
application and so definitely check
those out and I guess in closing I just
want to say like looking forward it's
been another great year for the NGO
community interest in go continues to
grow and I think we as a community have
done a great job of kind of building
using the language to its fullest extent
building amazing things on top of it and
really proving the value to other people
who are looking for better languages and
technology to adopt internally that
having said we have a long way to go a
long way ahead of us in terms of
building the community making sure that
it's inclusive and we welcome continue
to welcome beginners making sure we
understand the historical context and
kind of using that to inform the way we
think about you know designing features
of language that are not technically
features the language but are kind of
like part of the broader milieu that
remain open you know things like you
know a special comments like go
generates build tags things like that
that remain to be implemented language
that's something that we need to decide
oh and dependency management is another
big thing that's what I'm we need to
decide and settle on as a community and
so we should be cognizant of you know
the lessons learned in the past there
and then finally you know driving more
adoption of
the enterprise and continuing to
demonstrate that echo is a very general
purpose language and it's great tool for
building things that target a lot of
different platforms so you know it's
been an awesome right so far but we
still have a long way to go this is a
graph showing you know golang search
queries compared to queries for another
large and enterprising language that i
will not name but as you can see the
other language is slowly declining and
go is increasing at a rapid rate but
there's still a wide gap to be to be
bridged so special thanks to Bill
Kennedy Alan shreve and Dennis coldwell
they help this live blog the talks they
took a lot a lot off our plate so we're
very thankful to them and that's it for
me go and check out the the talks the
slides are up in in a repository the
videos will be up in two weeks and all
in all I'm just happy to be part of such
an amazing language community
any questions yeah how many people here
at hand go from athletic to like about
half maybe forty percent
any other questions
alright thanks